i need to figure out you know and you
had all the vpns you were staying under
the radar
yeah you're being extremely smart about
not getting caught yeah um
at what point did you hit a level
to where you're like starting to get
worried
when i started doing 100 orders a month
i was gonna say secret service showed up
well i mean that was quite a few times i
would go to grab a packet i'd be at
my dropbox store to go pick up a package
and
i somehow would they would be in there
looking for me or something i would be
like coming in or going out and i'd be
like and then another time i was at um i
think i was at a
like a borders bookstore or something
like that using
their vpn and one of my vpns had failed
on me
like i thought i was being protected and
i wasn't and
so you would be using public wi-fi yes
okay yeah yeah public wi-fi with a vpn
with a socks
you know i mean [ __ ] with a and i was
using russian proxies like i was doing
russian
sites where they would just list all
these proxies and this is back in the
day so you would have to you would have
to get all these proxies
and then you'd have to run them through
a checker one by one to make sure to see
if they were valid because there was
only like
there's only certain windows that these
vpns that these proxies were valid for
and then they would be no longer valid
because the ip addresses would cycle and
everything would get changed right
you know so it was like i had to go
through and you know use all the
these checkers and manually input the
the the ips so yeah my vpn
ended up failing on me and i didn't know
it and i think i was out of borders
books and this is the borders books i
kept using and this is my mistake i
just got comfortable you know i kept
going to the same place i mean i did
these big comfy chairs and i had my own
little
corner back away from everybody you know
what i mean this is my [ __ ] this is
my fraud corner this
is my this is what i do i go here i sit
i'm going around like that yeah it's my
little frog corner sorry this is this is
my spot
yeah vpn failed on me um
and yeah they just got hip to me and i
they tried to come to borders
i think they walked into borders one day
the same was it secret service agent
secretary
yeah the same secret service agent that
i had seen um at
my dropbox place how did you know he was
secret service
well you can always tell how they got
the
they got the high and tight they wear
the [ __ ] uh
the cargo they wear the cargo pants the
tan cargo pants with the tucked in polo
with the tucked in polo with the [ __ ]
uh
uh the bed the what do they call those
the lanyard right the lanyard with the
everyone if you google
google image [ __ ] what they all look
the same really they all look the same
yeah what's on the lanyard what's
hanging on off the lanyard
the secret service badge would they wear
the badge like they tuck it in
but they pull it out when you know what
i mean and and they have it ready for
you yeah
exactly i mean i could i could smell
police see police a mile away
you can always tell when somebody's
police yeah yeah especially when you're
when you're doing fraud and that's what
you're watching for were you like
did you i didn't know he was secret
service okay you didn't know he was
obviously that's why
i didn't know you secret service until i
seen him come into borders
because the only people that got pulled
with ip addresses and and with that kind
of
that kind of organization to be on you
like that
would be secret service because fb well
fbi and secret service but fbi doesn't
deal with that kinds of things okay
secret services secret service
they deal with all financial and you saw
all counterfeiting shady looking dude
who looked like a cop
and what did you like he carried himself
like the cop he was dressed like a cop
he i didn't so when i was you super
suspicious right so i had went to my my
i went to my uh i had something called
like an hq
so i don't know if you're familiar with
that it's uh it's like a a virtual
office
where okay yeah you can make they they
can do very employment verification you
can have packages shipped there
they can you know do mail they answer
phones for you so i had one of those
um and i was running you know packages
out of there or whatever like that
so i had seen i was going to pick up a
package one day and i uh i had seen
i was i think it was coming out of an
elevator and i seen those them walking
into the
to the office the the police i'm like
man this
something just hit me in the gut and
something just did not feel right at all
at all and there's courier guys there's
couriers that run in and out of the
building the to pick up packages or
whatever like that so i had paid one of
the couriers
to go and grab my packages for me at my
hq
okay and i went and sat in the parking
lot
so when when my courier comes out with
my packages sure enough
the bobo looking [ __ ] and then
the dude that was with him grab him
no yeah and that's when i knew right
then and there that that something was
wrong
but i didn't know it was my vpn you know
what i mean i thought it was i thought
that they maybe it was just
i didn't know how or why sorry at that
point in time
you know there's a um i was just
thinking about uh
i want you to see the uh the foia
cause like i got a ton of documents
right like i got a ton of stuff
that was showed up as i was ordering the
documents that are showing up verifying
this is true
this is true i'm dying to know and i
sent it to her she was like that's this
is amazing
i'm wondering what additional stuff she
came up with
do you see what i'm saying like i get a
movie about you john a documentary
well i hope so yeah i hope so yeah well
they got to sell it first yeah they're
going to like netflix or somebody but
they already make they're this i was
going to ask you that like is there
already a movie made about you
we're working on trying to get a deal
made the chick already
they make documentaries for netflix they
actually are making one right now for
netflix i think they just sold something
in netflix yeah
well yeah for sure they sold it because
they were they're down here
um what shooting it is it here you know
what's funny
but she told me sarasota but then she
wants to meet you and
anyway she's in florida they're in
florida right now and they're supposed
to meet with him
um but i was just wondering about that
when you said that i thought freedom of
information
it's interesting to see because you
don't know what's going on behind the
scenes
like i don't know how they knew what or
when or when to be where when
obviously you know because i'm not i'm
not on their team right
so when you get all the freedom of
information act [ __ ] it all it's all in
there
like all the reports all the documents
everything's in there
yeah every every interaction every
interaction any piece of paper that's
attached to my name that has anything to
do with any of these cases there's
there's paperwork on it and all of that
can be
released through freedom of information
keep in mind i could get everything yeah
first of all he was gone
he left way before me yeah how many
years you said it today you said it's
been five years yeah it's been five
years since i've seen you
but when but you left out 2015. oh yeah
[ __ ]
i got in 2019. yeah so yeah
so but i'm saying i was just thinking
like it was it was funny all the
different things that
like when his brother's police report
when his brother got arrested like i
have the whole police report so
i know like he used the car you know why
his brother got caught
why when he was when he went uh he was
so he goes back he goes back up to
michigan
and starts carting again who does his
brother his brother
remember he went on the run he went but
he starts carting again in michigan he
got caught got released
in florida and then goes back up there
starts carting again
um and then when he was carting he uses
a card
so he uses a card buy something like
[ __ ] fur like he ran it up for four
or five grand i think
i actually have was it that much yeah i
actually have the um
what not not just at target it was over
the throughout the day the same card
yeah same card because i actually have
from the bank
where it's like whatever 3 900 or 4200
whatever
around four grand he ran up this card
well here's the funny thing
so the card so he gets the
stuff and he leaves well
the woman gets notified by the by the
bank saying hey your car's been run up
or whatever
she then she goes okay well oh gosh this
is all around here
this target is right up the street
she calls the target and they're like
yeah i know okay yeah and she's like
okay well
she talks to them and they're like yeah
there's nothing we can do she calls they
call the police they go yeah just fill
out the police report she says no no
it's right down the street they have
surveillance cameras
i want you to go down there and look at
the she throws such a [ __ ] stink she
makes the police do their job
it was a karen they actually it was
definitely a carrier
they actually get up they drive down
there they get they look on the
surveillance photos they actually get
the name because his brother used like a
his brother used his own id with the the
strip
and they actually get his brother's id
they look in the phone book
find out where he lives go there open
the door it's [ __ ] swag everywhere
they open the door and [ __ ] it's him
he's the cop just saw him on the
just swag stolen merchant whatever it's
all it's an older term i've never heard
it's a boomer turner
sweatshirt i know it's swag
not in that context so it's it's
basically it
oh there's all these places filled with
[ __ ] with uh with stolen stuff or
whatever uh stuff yeah i was a [ __ ]
gift card
yeah just and he arrested right there
but i mean it was the victim wasn't
willing to just
roll over and go okay she was like oh no
she put up a stink
you go down there you look on the
surveillance photo and that's the
article there's a huge article that was
written up about his brother
wow you know talk about it they make it
sound like it's like a big deal and
stuff it's like you know
the five was four or five grand but so
anyway
i'm sorry that's when your brother first
got busted right no second time that was
after me and him got ran out of walmart
uh
after yeah but i have that police report
i had the police report
of the interviews of the screenshots of
the cards
of the ever all everything so that's the
kind of stuff that you know
i kept getting in and then like the time
you almost got caught
um and uh buying a gun in the uh
like he there's there were i was getting
documents in the stories that he never
even told me
yeah here in tampa yeah yeah he he
didn't even tell me like literally i'm
reading this
this hillsborough county sheriff's
report and i'm reading the report going
what the [ __ ] is this
yeah i had a warrant for my arrest a
federal warrant for my arrest
they did not i didn't know and i'm at a
gun store and i'm trying to buy i'm
trying to purchase a [ __ ] firearm
and they they're doing a background
check on me the police are on their way
up there to arrest me
and i just finally get sick of [ __ ]
waiting around i'm like you know what
i'm over it and i leave
and i i 10 minutes after i leave five
minutes after i leave the sheriff show
up to arrest me
yeah yeah and they call him yeah let you
understand
i was in prison when i got this report
and i completely forgot about this whole
this whole thing and i was on the phone
calling and i'm like hey bro
i got a report in and he's like oh yeah
yeah yeah they why you know i left they
wouldn't give me the thing and that
and i was wondering why they were acting
weird after after they like after that i
gave him the information i ran my
information the dude was acting [ __ ]
kind of strange behind the counter
because i guess he knew the police were
coming to arrest me you know i mean so
so something just didn't sit right now i
looked at my wife and i was like we
gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here you know
something's [ __ ] good something's
weird the cop even wrote up the phone
call when he called him
he's like hey is this john bozey he's no
man my name is jay or whatever you said
he said like my name's tom or whatever
right yeah he's like now you got the
wrong number wrong number but this isn't
he hangs up on him but the cop writes up
the whole thing
and so i tell him that i'm like you
never told me that story he's like yeah
i remember that's right
i mean there was all these things that
were talking about this earlier i was
like and years later when i got busted
i got i got arrested i got i was in
hillsborough county jail um
and but i was a federal i was on a
federal hold so federal inmates don't
get held at hillsboro they get shipped
out to pinellas
and they hold all the federal inmates
that uh at pinellas well they did
then i mean they had a contract i'm not
sure if they do anymore but um
the the dude who cop that came to pick
me up from hillsboro to transfer me
pinellas was the same one that came to
arrest me at the gun shop
and he's like you know i was i i got
there 10 minutes after you left i was
coming to arrest you
yeah the sheriff's deputy got there
first yeah that's the report i got
okay but he's saying that the secret
service
they also should i think he was yeah he
was like a u.s marshal or something like
that or something yeah i don't remember
who was transferring me but he was like
i'm i was the one that came
came to arrest you but i barely i just
barely missed you and he's like i went
to
whatever address you put on your on the
application i filled out for the
background checkered like the the gun
form or whatever he's like yeah it was
just like a vacant apartment or
something
and i was like yeah it's i have a habit
of not ever putting where i live
or any proper information on anything
and it's it's
it's hurting me now because now i'm like
a legitimate
like citizen of you know in society and
i'm trying to like function properly and
it's like
i've got all these habits where i just
don't put down wrong phone numbers for
[ __ ] i don't ever give my address out
where i live i don't have my
my driver's license registered to the
address my physical home address i don't
put
any utilities in my name i just yeah i'm
used to living life on the lam you know
used to [ __ ] always having warrants
or
you know a paranoid life somebody
chasing me for child support or some
[ __ ]
you know what i mean oh yeah i got a
couple of those
i've been ducking those for a while
um so yeah you know and those habits now
are are really they're hard for me to to
get out of
how long has it been since you got out
five years five years yeah i've been out
five years
all right so at what point at some point
between from when you first started
noticing these secret service agents
hovering around you you figured out who
they were they were getting close
they're getting close yeah yeah so now
you must be getting like way more
paranoid because these [ __ ] guys are
on you like they know who you are
yeah they're trying to find they know
what's going on online they know how to
[ __ ] they know that the tech the
technology of the vpns and yeah
and whatever they know what you're doing
on the forums the buying and selling of
stuff
yeah i think at this point they knew who
i was and what i was doing they just
didn't know who i was they didn't know
you looked like
they didn't know like yeah they didn't
know my they know who i was right
but you how many did you have a bunch of
fake identities oh yeah i mean i could
print i could print driver's licenses
right and i had access to hundreds of
thousands of people's information
at any given point in time i could buy i
mean i had contacts i could
i could call somebody like listen i need
500 first name
last name burst abroad i'm sorry first
name last name date of birth and social
security number so matt cox you were
basically like
the beta version of john bozeak
matt cox was the he's the analog person
the analog version that cox was
doing everything analog he was actually
going to homeless people and and
acting like he had a survey and having
them you know write their information
down
on the ground
yeah boots on the ground wow
that's [ __ ] yeah i'm going in the i'm
actually going in the bank and filling
out paperwork
yeah getting it out in cash he's filling
it out online
he's having it transferred yeah so at
any given time i could get
i could be anybody i wanted to be
because i could just make the driver's
license and
even if i didn't i know how to steal
identities so i could just go to a i
could
you know get i can get anybody's birth
certificate all i need is your first
name your date of birth and your social
security number
i can get your background check i can
pull your credit file once i do those
two things i can get your birth
certificate once i get your birth
certificate i can go
straight to the dmv and i can get a
driver's license in your name
with your birth certificate so now i'm
i'm i'm whoever i want to be
right and i in and that's you know
that's relatively easy that's peanuts